see each of us on the screen
individually
please announce yourself by name when
speaking and if you want to
refer to anything in the offices a
report
can you pers first clearly state the
relevant page and number
and paragraph number and give us time to
everybody to get to that particular page
and if you should hear the fire alarm go
off
it means the wife has worked for dinner
let me know when the livestream is
working
councillor ward has got his hand up
that's the award thank you chairman did
you i
have now put my uh video on so members
of the public can see me
do you require all members um to be
visible
please i
perhaps you'll guide me on that side
here i believe i'm correct in saying
the members have to be heard and can be
here and can be heard but not
necessarily have the
uh video on but i think it would be best
if the video was on
that's absolutely correct chairman
so are we on live stream sonia
yes okay okay
okay right um welcome to the russia
district council's remote meeting
of the investment board and welcome to
anyone watching
via the live stream
item number one on the agenda
is apologies do we have any apologies
sonia
no everyone's present chairman okay
then on that basis i assume that there
are no substitute members
there are none uh
non-members attending sonia could you
read out the names of those non-members
attending
certainly we have councillor stanley
son you're a little you're a little on
the quiet side son you're having
difficulty here
we have councillor stanley councillor
milne
and councillor mrs rowe thank you
gender item four uh the minutes of the
meeting held on the 16th of july
2020 uh the members
in agreement that the
minute notes are um
can i put it this way around that if any
member has an objection to that
please signify if not i'll take it that
there but he's happy with them
i see no raised hands so on that basis i
take it to the no minutes are accepted
item five receive decorations of
interest
members are there any decorations of
interest
sonja i'm not sure whether i need to
declare interest as
ward counsellor for uh the area of
cherry orchard park
no that's fine chairman
okay which moves us swiftly on to
item number six
and the cherry orchard maximizing the
potential cherry orchard jubilee country
park
uh mr market hotten assistant director
of place and environment
will now introduce the report after this
over to you
uh thank you chairman good evening
members um
i should be brief the report summarizes
and seeks approval for the appended
master plan
which outlines our vision for cherry
altar country park
the master plan was developed in
consultation with the associated member
working group
and the friends group and was drawn up
by alan scott who are specialists in
landscape
architecture and design and uh tend to
do a lot of these sort of public place
design work that you may see
sort of a wall bringing stuff around the
country so they come come with good
credit credits of credentials
um the master plan is a is a visual um
map-based interpretation of the aims and
objectives of the council's intent to
develop the park
and identify six broad zones within the
park
as you can find in the summary of the
report at 3.8
key concepts within the plan are the
improvements of access in particular
footpaths linking raley through
to the business park the development of
our visitor hub at the eastern end of
the park
and the enhancement of biodiversity
across the site particularly around the
lake
and woodland areas uh should members be
minded to approve
the report it's envisioned that the
working group will
move uh the master plan forward looking
at particular aspects of it
and identifying opportunities as they
come forward um to seek to sort of add
some flesh to the bones
so to speak um remember that concludes
my
my brief summary of of this sort of
outline of the master plan
um i'm happy to take questions thank you
thank you
i'm off from you it works better um
members uh marcus hot and adam aldridge
are quite both quite happy to take
questions
uh are there any questions from members
um
i see council award has put his hand up
castle award
thank you very much chairman uh yes i
would like to know who the membership
of that working party are please
thank you you're gonna you're going to
test my memory now so i apologize if i
do miss anyone off
um uh it was it was a while back since
we sort of formed this so
uh councillor eves um councillor um
um gooding i believe was on there as
well i'm looking to see if
if i may require some help councillor um
williams was a chair of the meeting
group
we also had uh councillor tony carter on
the group
and um i believe was councillor laurin
shaw
thank you
marcus can i just say we had two people
from the uh
friends of cherry orchard park involved
as well
sorry thank you yes thank you for
reminding me yes so um
with members aside yes we had um two two
representatives from there
one was the chair of the group who's um
penny and and the other one was um
adam you may have to help me out here on
the names of the other two i think the
secretary of the uh the friends group
thank you very much that's what i
on you um are you smoking
no i'm not i'm i'm sitting in front of
the fire
all right we suspected you might be
smoking it
just might be hot where you are okay
okay
um council asperian you have your hand
up
thank you chairman uh mark as i i you
know i've read the the master plan one
thing another
at what stage if ever can we go down the
road of
perhaps introducing a ranger of some
description
into the to the master plan other than
just
structural um and um
landscaping issues um
is that ever going to be part of the
master plan does it become master
part of the master plan
i think the short answer i wouldn't say
is part of the master plan as such
because
technically it it's a concept plan um
council sparing so
how it's delivered is the detail so it
may be that we choose to um
have a range do that or it could be that
you would ask volunteers to undertake
there's there's a range of ways which
can be done so so this is just a
conceptual plan to decide then
you would expect there to be a further
stage beyond this it starts looking if
you like
how you actually deliver the detail okay
thank you
any other questions members
yes williams
thank you chairman yeah i'd just like to
thank uh id marcus sultan and
the members of the working group the
most helpful
throughout thank you very much
any other questions members anybody else
want to come in
okay i see no further hands uh members
there are two
recommendations set out on page 6
6.4 paragraph 6.1 of the report
i'll read them through uh one that the
cheryl should
become um that the cherry orchard
jubilee country
park master plan be approved and two
that member
working group seeks to explore and
identify opportunities
that can deliver deliver against the
action set up within the master plan
members are you happy to vote on these
two recommendations together
i will assume that if nobody puts up
their hand
that that is acceptable
yeah i see no hands okay
uh voting will be done by a roll call of
names
when someone calls out your name please
indicate
if you wish to have a recorded vote and
then whether you are voted
for against or for or against the
recommendation
or you wish to abstain sonja over to you
councillor fd please
no recorded vote and four thank you
thank you councillor eves
a recorded vote and four thank you thank
you
cancer mrs gooding no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you son you're
quite quiet again
okay counsellor you are no
uh no recorded votes and four
councillor lucas skill no recorded vote
and four councillor newport
uh no recorded voting for
councillor mrs shaw no recorded vote on
before the recommendation
councillor sparing
sorry i'm having problems with this
microphone you see me no recording
potent for
sonia thank you councillor steptoe
no recorded vote and four
council award thank you sonya no
recorded vote and
four councillor williams
thank you sonya no recorded vote and for
both recommendations thank you
councillor wilson no recorded vote and
for the recommendation
and councillor whatton thank you so much
vote and
for the recommendations thank you that's
unanimous
chairman hey members that's uh you know
your name let's we'll move on to
item
okay item seven
councils local authority training
companies
the report will be introduced by naomi
lucas
assistant director of resources
naomi over to you
thank you chair so this report
um sets out the financial position of
the local
um authorities trading companies
otherwise known as the latkos um
members will be aware that um
these were established in 2016
and there's three separate and kind of
arms of their company so there's the the
holding company green great gateway
trading limited
um which yeah it's just the holding
company
there's green gateway trading
development which is a subsidiary of
that holding company which is not
currently trading
and there is green gateway trading
grounds maintenance limited
which um again is a subsidiary of their
holding company
which is currently trading under their
public contracts regulations act
2015 so the council is the 100
shareholder of all of these companies
and as such
is required to approve the accounts of
these companies
so investment board tonight is asked to
consider consider the accounts um
and the annual report of the directors
um and then refer that on to full
council for approval
so i was just going to summarize a high
level the um
the position of of those trading
companies so
the holding company um has had no
financial transactions during
during this year and it maintains um
net assets of just of one pound um and
similarly the trading
company and the development arm again
has not had any
um transactions during the financial
year and again
has um net assets of a pound so that the
main
um accounts which you're asked to
consider tonight are the
um grounds maintenance company um of
which
the directors of the company are all on
um
this call tonight so um i will be
available to um
ask answer any questions that you may
have in in terms of the detail of those
accounts
um but in summary um they have
um managed to achieve a small net profit
of just um under um
four thousand pounds or three thousand
six hundred and three pounds
um and those accounts have been prepared
um on behalf of the council um by by
um ventums and also audited so they have
been through a proper due diligence
process
so the the company itself is now in the
fourth year of
trading um and the contracts that it has
with the council is due to expire on the
5th of december of the next
year so um
under the terms in which the the company
operates with the council
and is limited in terms of the
other contracts that it can take on um
from
from the private sector so um under the
terms of the technical agreement that
that it operates under
um it can't take on additional contracts
um to a value of greater than 20
of of them the company's turnover
so it does mean that the company is um
basically dependent on the council's um
main contracts
um which as i said is due to be um due
to expire
the next financial year unless it's
renewed so
um given that that um date is coming up
fairly soon
and the executive agreed in september
that
they would commission a piece of work um
by the council um with an external
consultant to look at
um future options for delivery of the um
both the grounds maintenance and the
street cleansing services
and that will enable the council to
determine whether it wishes
um ggt grounds maintenance to continue
the contract beyond that date
or whether it wishes to look at
alternative options for delivery of that
service so that will obviously
be a key um sort of determinant of the
future of the company
so further to that the report just also
notes that obviously with the
impending retirement of the managing
director of the council
um who is also the director of green
gateway trading limited
um there will have to be an alternative
um
put in place to fulfill that role and
it's proposed that
um that will be this the current
strategic director angela hutchins who
will fulfill that going forward
so that's probably all i'm
going to say at this point obviously
there's a few recommendations to notes
um within the reports but if members do
as i say have any particular questions
um either around the
accounts for the company or the actual
directors report which is appended as a
confidential appendix then um i'll take
direction from the chair but i believe
would have to go into
we might have to go into pnc um if if
they want to be discussed in more detail
thank you chair
members um we do have the opportunity to
uh call on matt harwood white and dawn
tribe
to answer questions uh at a higher level
uh
do you wish me to move the uh meeting
into private and confidential
if anybody's against that can you put
your hand up if not i'll take it that we
are we don't need to go into private and
confidential
did you want to move into private
confidential i'm not sure
um
if i ask a question i'm not sure whether
it would be pnc or not
to make it woolly green
my development i don't know the purpose
okay um
perhaps i can get some advice on that
from
i think don't i think
yes i think you can answer that outside
of the uh
private confidential know me yeah
thank you thank you chair um so um
when the company um structure was
originally set up obviously
slightly before my time but i i believe
it was just the most sort of um
uh efficient and effective way to set up
the company structure at that time given
we
that we didn't know whether there would
be future kind of trading opportunities
or arms that we wish to pursue
um so essentially another subsidiary
sort of shell was set up
um just with the um uh
just to keep the options open in terms
of whether council would want to pursue
a separate sort of trading arm in future
um um as it happens that that that
hasn't been pursued at this time
so um it's sort of sitting there dormant
um
but that it hasn't yeah so it's just
been sitting as a shell company really
without without any trading activity
thank you sorry uh naomi can i just ask
to chair yes please do classrooms um
there's nothing being thought of down
that line at the moment then
can i just confirm that yeah there's
nothing being actually pursued
on that at the moment right okay thank
you very much
okay uh council award is it a question
outside of pnc
yes yes it is indeed
yeah thank you um basically i i assume
that the
that the fees paid to company house uh
on those
uh are paid normally through the
accounts is that correct
because you're limited company yes
yes so so any any transactions relating
to the company would go through the
accounts for the company
no i mean companies house registered a
company's house yes they're they're all
the
all the all of the accounts registered
at companies house yeah
thank you okay
uh councillor woodson again is it a
question that doesn't require pnc
uh absolutely it is chairman thank you
very much indeed uh no problem
um my question really relates to the
governance
of green gateway trading limited uh i
note that there is one
sole director and i just wonder in terms
of company structure whether or not it
would be wise actually
to have two company uh directors if uh
um i would have thought that would be a
better governance process
but uh perhaps i could have advice on
that please chairman
amy do you want to answer that um
if i if i may i might refer to um angela
laura as a monitoring officer on this
one but um
uh yeah i understand that there's only a
requirement to have one director and i
think
just due to the sort of the limited
resources and a number of people we've
got available to fulfill the roles
across the different functions of the
trading company i think it's been more
operationally viable to just have the
one director but that's obviously
something that we could potentially
consider but i'm i'll refer to angela
laura on that point
andrew law did you want to come in on
that point german yes
uh miss lucas is correct uh there's only
a requirement
for one director but um it is something
we can
consider outside of this meeting um
should the leader
wish us to chair but if i might come
back
yes sir i would certainly like
i believe it is good governance good
practice to actually have more than one
especially in the situation
as a local authority and certainly with
your permission chairman
i would like us to explore that
opportunity please
certainly um i don't personally have a
problem with that
perhaps we can do that offline and then
report back to the investment board
on the options there thank you very much
okay uh councilor wilson
again is it a question outside that
remains outside pnc
yeah i'm not going to refer to the
exempt
matters at all um just following up from
section 151 officer
um the in the report we say that there
was a 3600 pound
profit what what was expected that
that's my first question um
second one was what what's our
anticipated
profit for the following year uh and
then finally
i have to say that your your um report
sounded quite gloomy about the
the prospects for um the company
um but would it ever be brought back
in-house
mommy did you want to come back to that
yeah um so the
company was only ever sort of set up to
um achieve a small
profit really um primarily because the
the main advantage of having the trading
company
is actually to deliver the operational
sort of cost saving
to the council so that most of the
benefit of the company is actually being
delivered through the operational saving
on the
on the contract itself um obviously any
um
profits that the the um trading company
makes are taxable
profits so um yeah it's not necessarily
um in the council's advantage for it to
be making a
a huge profit in any case um but in
terms of the future options of of the
company
um we obviously haven't made any
decisions at this point in
in time um but as i said the executive
has
commissioned this piece of work to look
at all options for delivery
um i wouldn't necessarily say it's
gloomy but i think we have to and
obviously consider all of our our
options for delivery
um in life of our you know financial
position and look at which ones would
deliver best value for money for the
for the council so i think that piece of
work needs to be um
um completed and reviewed and and a
decision made
um following following that review um
if if you wanted to delve any more into
the
um actual um yes financial position of
the company i think because the accounts
themselves are in p and c
we might have to go into example
thank you yeah yeah we want to go into
it but
i i suppose hypothetically
if the company ceased to exist what
would happen to the assets of it would
they go back to the council
so that the council is 100 shareholder
of the company so i mean we would
obviously take the appropriate advice in
terms of how the company itself if it
was to be wound down would be run down
but the assets would obviously have to
be liquidated and as you say
um returned to the shareholder if
appropriate but we would take financial
advice at that point in time
as for hatchings i've seen your hand pop
up and then disappear and they pop up
again
several times i'm assuming you want to
come in on this point
yes please share if i may um if it
assists members to
remember that a local authority trading
company established
under regulation 12 of the public
contracts regulations 2015
means that the only business which this
company can transact
up to uh eighty percent of its net um
annual turnover over
amortize over a three year period is is
that of the
of the council itself so it's not
comparing it to a
private limited company that's trading
on the open market
it was set up primarily to deliver the
grounds maintenance contracts on behalf
of the council and it has
uh has delivered a saving in respect of
that it's ongoing work in the business
case
that um is covered more in the um
chairman's annual report uh describes
the um the future of the of the company
uh and links as naomi has said in
relation to the its future use
so it's not that it's a gloomy picture
or that it's a relatively small
margin it's doing what we set it up to
do
council rewards i have your see your
hand it up yeah thank you very much
dear channel i think it's worth
reminding ourselves to those
councillors who are reasonably new
to the fact that green gateway was set
up
uh realistically after the failure of
two other companies
that were service providers and we went
out we decided
to go down the road of looking at
some kind of self-provision and we came
up
with this idea of a a latko which would
serve the purposes so
i i think it's important just to bear in
mind that it was under those
circumstances
of two companies that failed to deliver
services
that this was actually formed thank you
just before i go to you council newport
um
councillor i'm sorry matt harwood white
did you want to come in
not this point thank you chairman um i
didn't have my hand raised
that's okay i i had a message that you
might want to come in okay council
newport uh again you're providing it's
not uh mata under pnc
thank you chairman um yeah what happens
in uh
to alepco in the event of a
combined authority or council merger
and what would happen to
those uh within the contracts
that you ex provide external services to
would there be any penalties
only did you want to come on on that
um yeah i i won't profess to be an
expert in terms of all the mechanics of
how
um uh sort of contracts would transfer
under any change of governance
arrangement but there is protocols for
that and contracts can be innovated
to um new um sort of um uh
governance arrangements where it's
required um
so for example where the the nhs says
you know
functions of the nhs have transferred
into um county for example public health
and the contracts associated with that
getting ovated over
obviously there is some legal work and
around i'm picking that
um in terms of financial penalties um
i mean that's not the way we've set up
the company so there's no financial
penalties or anything
um within the contract at the moment so
i don't really
or see that being um a particular issue
in this case
um uh but again i i might refer
back to either andrew or angela
hutchinson in terms of
the specifics if if you need anything
more than that thank you
angela hutchins did you want to come in
on that point yes thank you chairman
um it's important to remember members
that a company has
legal personality of itself so it exists
in law separate and distinct from its
shareholders
so the council is a 100 shareholder of
all of these companies in the event that
the council ceased to exist because of
local government reorganization
there would be a sale uh transfer of
those shares
from rochefort district council to the
successor body
and the company would continue unless
until the shareholders
agreed to dissolve the company in
relation to
contracts that were uh in operation or
owned by the company at the point at
which it was transferred
naomi's absolutely right those contracts
would no vote to the successor body
okay thank you uh councillor mike lucas
lucaskill
thank you chairman um angela hutchings
did you
say just now that for the first three
years
the council had to do at least 80
percent uh
the trading company sorry had to do at
least 80 percent work for the council
before the work no no it's not it's not
time limited it isn't
it's entirely the um raison d'etre of
the company itself
uh councillor lucas gill the cup the
company at no
point in its lifetime can do work
for another authority other than
rochefort district council
which exceeds more than 20 percent of
its annual turnover amortized over a
three-year period so it's the net
turnover value of the company which
determines its
um um what that threshold will be and
the reason for that is because
regulation 12
allows watchful district council to
award a contract directly
to green gateway gm limited
without going through a procurement
process and so it's important to
abide by the obligations under
regulation 12 of the public contracts
regulations 2015.
okay thank you could i just come back
chairman uh please do
uh when this company was proposed to be
set up
i did say was it possible they could do
work for the public you know like hedge
cutting and such like
uh would that be another stream of
income
um no it's a public it's a local
authority trading company
um councillor lucas gill that's why i
say it's not the same as any other
private limited company it can only work
for public bodies it cannot work for
private companies or private individuals
well that's a bad restriction then isn't
it it's the pre
is the quid pro quo of not having to go
through a procurement process
thank you is it possible for that they
could work for a charitable organization
no because a charitable organization is
not is not a public body
okay okay i don't see any other hands
but can i just clarify that there is no
none of the members wish to go into the
pnc to ask those questions under pnc
i see no hands requesting that
okay let's uh move on then
[Music]
um a paragraph 10.1
on page 7.3 there are three
recommendations
remember the members the first
recommendation is for
noting so can i take that particular
item first
but the annual report of the directors
of bring gateway gm limited set up in
the exempt appendix a
be noted is members happy with that
agreed chairman agreed chairman
agreed great great
excuse me members
okay uh recommendation
two introductions be appointed as
replacement director
for sean scotton in green gateway
training limited and recommendation
three
which is recommending to the council
that the accounts of the lack code
for the financial year 2019-20
set out in centerpendix b be approved
members are you happy to vote on these
two recommendations together
if there is anybody that does not wish
to do that
please raise your hand
okay members i'll take it that you are
happy for that uh to be dealt with as
uh both items together
voting will be done and vocal remains
when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
on whether you are voting for or against
the recommendation
or you wish to abstain sonja over to you
thank you um councillor fd
i recorded vote and for the
recommendations thank you
councillor eves no recording voting for
thank you thank you councillor mrs
gooding
no recorded vote and for both
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor yuanu
no recorded vote and for both re
recommendation
councillor lucas no recorded vote and
for
both councillor newport
no recorded vote on four
cancer mrs shaw no recorded vote um
for both recommendations thank you sonya
councillor sparing no recorded vote and
for the recommendations
councillor no recorded vote
and for the recommendations council
award
uh no and for sonia thank you
councillor williams thank you sonia uh
no and for both recommendations cancer
wilson
and four thanks and councillor wootton
thank you sonia now and for the
recommendations
chairman that's unanimous okay many
thank you
many thanks members that's the unanimous
uh uh
return members
that concludes the business for the for
the meeting
thank everyone everybody for attending
and
please stay safe in these uh
unpredictable times
good night everybody nice to see you
good